GENERAL MANAGER DAVE GET
THEM AND SPOKE TO THE MEDIA
TODAY IN ADVANCE OF THE 2021
DRAFT HERE. HE IS ON THE
IMPORTANT SUBJECT OF HOW TO
PROPERLY SCOUT COLLEGE
PLAYERS WHO OPTED OUT OF THE
2020 SEASON DO
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC HERE'S
GET THEM.
IT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING
THAT SOME OF THE OPT-OUT KIDS
DID A GREAT JOB SHOWED UP AT
THE APPROACH DAYS AND AND
JUST YOU KNOW, WE'RE
OUTSTANDING OUTSTANDING AND
THERE ARE A FEW OF THE
AND THERE ARE A FEW OF THE
OPT-OUT GUYS THAT SHOWED UP
AND LOOKING LIKE ME, YOU KNOW,
SO SO IT'S THAT WASN'T REAL
GOOD ON FOR THEM, YOU KNOW,
BUT IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW, SO
ON FOR THEM, YOU KNOW, BUT
IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW, SO IT'S
YOU DO IT ON A CASE-BY-CASE
BASIS RYAN YOU LOOK AT THE
CASE-BY-CASE BASIS RYAN YOU
LOOK AT THE FILM AND YOU KNOW,
YOU COME UP WITH IT AND YOU
MAKE IT
DECISION DUDE ON THE RIGHT
STARTED LAST STARTED TO SMILE
MANY FOUND OUR BOSS MAY SEE
THIS AT SOME POINT. I'M GOING
TO I'M GOING TO I'M GOING TO
STRAIGHTEN UP QUICKLY, BUT
HEY, I DON'T KNOW THAT. I'M
GOING TO FALL SOMEBODY WHO
WHO DEALT WITH?
SOMETHING THAT NONE OF US
EVER THOUGHT WE'D HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IN OUR LIFETIMES
WHERE OR SHUT OFF FROM THE
WORLD WHERE WE'RE STAYING
HOME. WHERE WERE AVOIDING
OTHER PEOPLE. THERE'S ONLY SO
MUCH THAT YOU CAN DO AT HOME
AND EVERYONE REACTED TO THIS
DIFFERENTLY AND IF A GUY HAS
HIGH-END TALENT AND JUST
HAPPENS TO BE OUT OF SHAPE
RIGHT NOW. WELL YOU GET THEM
INTO YOUR BUILDING YOU'LL
WHIP HIS ASS INTO SHAPE AND
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A HELL
OF A FOOTBALL PLAYER. SO
THERE ARE TEAMS OUT THERE.
THIS IF OTHER TEAMS SAY CAN'T
DRIVE THIS GUY BECAUSE HE'S
BUILT LIKE DAVE GENTLEMEN,
GET HIM INTO SHAPE AND AND
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A GREAT
PLAYER. SO I'M REALLY TORN
ON THIS. I REALLY AM BECAUSE
THERE'S NO RULE BOOK OUT
THERE FOR HOW TO DEAL WITH
THE PANDEMIC IT AFFECTED SO
MANY DIFFERENT PEOPLE IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS. I'M NOT
MAKING EXCUSES. I'M JUST
SAYING THAT IF YOU START
SAYING, WELL, THIS GUY'S
GREAT PLAYER AND HE PLAYED
GREAT IN 2019, BUT HE OPTED
OUT AND YOU KNOW,
HE'S NOT IN FOOTBALL.
SHAPE RIGHT NOW AND HE'S A
LITTLE BIT SPONGY AND LITTLE
BIT SOFT AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO GET IN THE WEIGHT ROOM.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WELL DO
IT JUST DO IT. HE'S GOING TO
BE PART OF THE TEAM AND
YOU'RE GOING TO APPROACH IT
THAT WAY TO GET THEM IN
FOOTBALL SHAPE. I JUST I
THINK THAT THAT IF YOU GET
TOO CAUGHT UP IN THAT MILES
YOU'RE GOING TO POTENTIALLY
PASS ON A GUY THAT OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE HELPED YOUR
FOOTBALL TEAM WIN GAMES. SURE.
YEAH, AND I THINK THAT PART
OF IT TOO IS JUST THAT YOU
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
DOING THESE THINGS ON A
STORY FOR YOU KNOW WHY THEY
MAY HAVE OPTED OUT IN THE
COVID YEAR. IT'S PROBABLY
DIFFERENT FROM ANOTHER GUY
STORY. IT'S PROBABLY
DIFFERENT THAN FROM ANOTHER
GUY'S STORY. SO I THINK THAT
A LOT OF THESE GM'S HAVE BEEN
SAYING, YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK AT
THIS ON A CASE-BY-CASE BASIS.
WHY DID THEY OPT OUT? WHAT
WERE THEY DOING? WHEN THEY
DID OPT OUT? YOU KNOW, HOW
WERE THEY TRAINING AND I
THINK IF YOU SEE SOMEBODY AT
A PRO DAY THAT DOESN'T
EXACTLY LOOK LIKE THEY WERE
IN THE BEST FOOTBALL SHAPE.
WELL, IT STANDS TO REASON
THAT THEY SHOULDN'T BE
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T PLAYED
FOOTBALL.
ALL SINCE THE 2019 SEASON SO
I THINK AS LONG IS TEAMS ARE
REALLY TRYING TO DELVE INTO
FIGURING OUT. WHAT EXACTLY IS
UP WITH THE PLAYER, YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE THERE THEY CAN DO ALL
THESE DIFFERENT ZOOM
INTERVIEWS AND YOU KNOW,
WHETHER THEY'RE PLAYING
ROCHAMBEAU OR WHATEVER ELSE
THEY'RE DOING THEY CAN FIGURE
OUT EXACTLY WHAT THIS GUY
LOOKS LIKE FROM THE INSIDE,
YOU KNOW WHAT THEIR WHAT HIS
INTERNAL MAKEUP IS AND I
THINK WHEN YOU'RE GOING AFTER
A PLAYER IN THE FIRST ROUND,
ESPECIALLY YOU HAVE TO
FIGURE THAT OUT ALMOST
MORE THAN WHAT THEY APPEAR TO
BE ON TAPE AND COLLEGE
BECAUSE YOU'RE PAYING THIS
GUY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
COME IN AND BE A STAR FOR
IF THEY WANT TO IF TEAMS WANT
TO SAY IF THEY'VE GOTTEN
WANTS TO SAY MAN, THAT GUY
LOOK LIKE ME, HE'S OFF THE
BOARD THEN YOU KNOW, THAT'S
FINE I GUESS BUT I THINK IF
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON WHY
YOU'RE DOING IT, THEN YOU'RE
PROBABLY DOING YOURSELF AND
THE TEAM A DISSERVICE. I HAD
NO IDEA THAT ROCHAMBEAU WAS
THE ALTERNATE NAME FOR
ROCK-PAPER-SCISSORS UNTIL
TODAY. HOW DID I LIVE NEARLY
FIFTY SIX YEARS AND NOT KNOW
THAT HERE'S DAVE GET THEM AND
TALKING ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY
OF TRADING OUT OF THE 11
SPOTS SOMETHING. HE'S NEVER
DONE. HE'S NEVER TRADED DOWN.
ROUND ONE AND THE GIANTS
HAVEN'T TRADED DOWN IN ROUND
ONE SINCE 2006 WHEN THE
STEELERS JUMPED UP TO GET
SANTONIO HOLMES. HERE'S
GELMAN.
YOU HAVE TO I TRIED IN THE
PAST HONEST IT HONEST I'VE
TRIED TO TRADE BACK, BUT IT'S
GOING TO BE VALUE. I'M NOT
GETTING FLEECED I
REFUSED TO DO IT AND IF YOU
KNOW, SOMEBODY WANTS TO MAKE
BAD TRADES BACK GOD BLESS
THEM AND BUT YOU KNOW, WE'VE
HAD OPPORTUNITIES I'VE TRIED,
YOU KNOW, AND THERE ARE YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE OTHER
PIECE OF THIS AND IS
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE A TRADE.
AND THE GUY THAT THE TEAM IS
TRAINING UP FOR GETS PICKED
IN FRONT OF YOU. I'VE HAD
WE'VE HAD THAT HAPPEN TO US.
WE GOT A TRAY WE GOT TO TRADE
AND THE SO-AND-SO SELECTS. NO
TRADE DAVE GO BY HANG THE
PHONE UP ON ME. SO THAT
HAPPENS TO I MEAN, IT'S
REALLY IT'S LIKE IT'S ALMOST
BECOMING URBAN MYTH.
THE REALITY A LOT OF TEAMS
READY TO TRADE DOWN NOT MANY
TRAINS TEAMS WILLING TO TRADE
UP AND ONE OF THE REALITIES
NEXT YEAR'S DRAFT PICKS WILL
BE MORE VALUABLE THAN THIS
YEAR'S BECAUSE NEXT YEAR YOU
CAN PROPERLY SCALP THIS YEAR.
YOU CAN'T PROPERLY SCOUT NO
COMBINE. NO PRIVATE WORKOUTS.
NO VISITS TO THE FACILITY.
HOPEFULLY NEXT YEAR THE FULL
ALLOTMENT OF SCOUTING TOOLS
WILL BE AVAILABLE. YOU KNOW,
WHAT THOUGH, MAN? I MEAN THAT
I TRIED I'M TELLING YOU I'VE
TRIED AND ALL THAT ALL THAT
WAS THAT KILLS ME EVERY TIME
TODAY AND I JUST EVERY TIME
MAN GETTLEMAN JUST YOU REALLY
JUST GET THE FEELING THAT HE
ALMOST DOESN'T LIKE THIS
REPUTATION THAT HE'S EARNED
AND HE ALMOST JUST SEEMS LIKE
HE WANTS TO BE ABLE TO TRADE
DOWN JUST TO MAKE US ALL BE
QUIET BECAUSE HE KEEPS BEING
TOLD THAT HE HATES TRADING
DOWN EH TRADING DOWN ON ME MY
GOODNESS MAN. IT'S HILARIOUS,
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
REALLY GOING TO TRADE DOWN
FROM 11. THEY COULD GET A DO
A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT PREMIUM
PLAYERS COULD STILL BE THERE
FOR THEM AT THE 11TH OVERALL
PICK, SO
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, I KNOW THAT
THERE WAS THAT REPORT THAT
THEY HAVE HAD INTERNAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT TRADING
BACK IN THE FIRST ROUND AND
MAYBE THEY'LL END UP DOING
THAT. BUT I JUST FEEL LIKE
THERE'S SO MUCH TALENT OUT
THERE THAT I DON'T KNOW WHY
NECESSARILY YOU WOULD DO THAT
IF THERE IS A PLAYER THAT YOU
REALLY FEEL LIKE CAN HELP YOU
WIN. I THINK IF YOU'RE AT
11:00 YOUR AT 11 PICK THE GUY
THAT YOU THINK CAN HELP YOU
WIN. AND IF YOU CAN'T IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT GUY THEN YEAH,
I GUESS TREA BACK BUT I IN
THIS PARTICULAR DRAFT, I
FEEL LIKE THERE'S GONNA BE
SOMEBODY THERE FOR THEM, TOO